most honorable man I know
[Applause]
[Music]
on her honor as a Tully on her honor as
a stark that you steal her last
cigarette she will cut your wife's
throat Michelle Bailey
[Applause]
The Wizard of width of wind show John
grass
half our visual effects budget goes
towards disguising this hideous ugliness
here he is in all this freakish glory
kit harington
[Applause]
the founder of the ginger Liberation
Front
gladly
[Applause]
he may no longer be the king in the
north
but he will always be 2010's
best-dressed man in Scotland richard
padded
[Applause]
[Music]
jawoll the bulliest want to say Edward
school and we do know your names
it may have taken her 10 years but the
mother of dragons is coming for you
[Applause]
[Music]
he maybe it may be the Shakespeare of
the seven kingdoms he may be the reason
we're all here today but he is not your
George our moderator today the man
with the best hair in show business
Elvis Mitchell I'm sorry about the
sunglasses oh you're so touched by that
incredible thing Emporium opening you
know the one thing that is missing from
Game of Thrones is voice to me why did
you wait to write the brothers out here
in San Diego is my first question to you
guys my actual first question is George
you heartless bastard
I understand that you tell your wife
whenever she asks about a favorite
character you say that person isn't
going to die but you don't really need
it is that true well I shouldn't really
talk about that but right I have many
characters so killing a few is always
more and creating new characters it is
job opportunities for actors actresses
and and I should say in my defense says
that David Mann have turned everything
up to 11 from the books they've killed
many characters who were still alive in
the books so I want to take some what's
their seaplane well speaking of that you
guys bought into Lisa it made me think
well maybe they're not gonna kill Rob
maybe he's gonna live maybe gonna spit
was that like a deliberate mislead to
give a different wife in the books well
it appears to work for you so that's
good no I mean it was we always knew
that they were all gonna die this is
part of the blueprint I was a rough day
when we brought the red wedding I
remember
Michelle and Richard the plank fictional
characters but it's the last time we're
going to work with ever really remember
that's Jenna again and we have a jumble
if you work in Bilbao favorite up crews
Irish and and they were crying and the
crew was crying on set which I've never
seen before it's such a testament to
Michelle and Richard and goona and
everyone else in the performances they
gave that these fictional deaths had
people on set and Uwe was coming they
all knew was coming
having impediment tears thank you here
whichever state you're crying on the
flight home after the day shoot is that
true yeah I am say what's your ego and
yeah I got it and I just got that I did
send crime to my home site
rows of people looking at this I was
crazy
but to find there's so many kind of
years since we started pilot and some
amazing friendships you know it was a
character same were exhausted just very
great friends sad to not be seeing no
it's July and I can feel like I should
be doing something that's an order
scenarios I've gotta be okay so I'm
missing hi
or Michelle week the books as you guys
are shooting which read ahead together
I knew many years I signed also I knew
upcoming I supposed to David down Brian
don't always stick to the book so but
you know you read the book and it's a
great reference to but your script is
reliable and that's what you were Duke
oh so my visa books rewarding think guys
Georgia Rose you whatever they want
everyone's have different things some
some actors like to read ahead and some
really want to be surprised and not know
I think there's a fear that if you know
where your character goes foreseen from
that you're kind of playing that ahead
so we completely leave it up to the
actors Peter does that work for you to
get too far ahead if you let's just
stick with it or in four or five years
when this is all over I think I'm going
to go back and read all of those
perspective but no I don't want to know
what's coming I want to know what this
happened but I don't want to know what's
coming so I stay away from we too far
into the future
help cease not know yeah yeah you become
a drag I would breathe fire
and I can
I think they like you kisses you guys
let me tell you I think weather was
interesting emotional and kind of funny
things is the last episode but you're
giving him a fond goodbye for that
conversation so much going on in this
bleep done that was a dialogue talk
about a fancy but have you guys figure
out how to get that emotional part by
which one of the things you got through
my usually brand-new I read that scene
because it's beautifully written it's
one is things in this show and has acted
in this show and this I really hate
buying smoke up David downs off
times but they're very good and it's
very easy I love fun fun seen some of
the most graceful sees the funnest was
it fun for you too rose enormous if it
wasn't but I think I was very much
wrapped up realizing you know she's
incredibly devastating left her in
sudden confusion I had some
conversations like the fact that these
two characters are even perspective she
was she finished that John Newland
Beauty right now she keeps her from
being killed on this episode she still
was the evidence in front of her is
forcing herself to believe this can
possibly be true yes totally Tokyo my
name is that devastation Frankie and the
traitor
suddenly in Episode nine when he does my
boy on horses it's just it's horrible
but there's that realization in a head
and she's like he's not gonna get away
with this I'm going to hunt it down yes
right you don't kill them even women do
Shuman about an arrow so like here I
have people evidences we first of all
congratulations
[Applause]
tell us about getting the news and
please pick English horse
alternative yeah I did I was at the Nike
with Miss Rose lately I'm hoping that
the Dean and Dan and that the show would
get some kind of a recognition I never
in a million years
yes sorry might now went up really
really early at 6 a.m. in the hotel
and so whilst trying to find things
differently alarm to turn it off I'm I
saw I was getting my school from someone
from HBO to talk about the amazing news
and it took about three phone calls to
kind of say better no energy yourself as
well didn't have such a great season is
sure your glass is so good you believe
your problem headaches just see what
she's going to the season to signal
reclaimed we need an e again at the end
of the season that was such a great note
over on the great way to play actually
talked about finding the character that
little you've gone through is yeah it
was it mean it's been a phenomenal
season it was it was a phenomenal season
to film it was amazing getting to your
the journey that she said she wanted you
think that she's peeking in episode 5
with the getting her army and then we
have the final final four seconds and
absolutely exhilarating to them really
amazing I'm David Nasser is absolute
geniuses and I remember going in there
lifting me up just naturally for enemies
you guys got the right nomination for
what Alvin
known locally as the I think it's called
the red wedding episode
which just strikes me when I met you
doesn't talk about this room kind of
dreading that all talk about
[Applause]
[Music]
I was hoping for sure it still is such a
beautiful piece of writing and together
so much have not said there's so much
sometimes I would say that was one I
mean there's so much that is the man
sitting at the other end of the table
would we read the books 2006 2006 we
knew immediately to me if we can make it
we can make this happen we can get this
to that place we get to that scene and
do justice to the just a holy of
that moment and then throw the book
across the room of that moment we gave
you with a throw remote control of the
way I threw my book that we would have
done something right and so yeah it was
exciting it was terrifying because it's
such a difficult difficult scene to pull
up and just coming back to the David
Nutter at all the director of the
episode is just such a legend and genius
and and so much of the success of that
episode is down down to him and of
course to the the people sitting to my
left on this panel just about your own
trepidations about the episode where
we've been waiting for it for so long
and you know all the readers of the
books have been waiting
and I think four years ago we said
something like if we can just get to the
red wedding we can die happy and then we
didn't even want to say the words red
wedding before because just became kind
of a spoiler so it was the scene that
cannot be mentioned I just remember
standing on set and watching Michelle up
to do these takes over and over again
and as they say so much it was about
mental phases of the characters and so
little to do with the dialogue and just
the face that Michelle makes when she
pulls up every spoken sleeve he sees the
chain maille toward the fish the look on
her face right before she cuts the
Walder Frey's wife's throat how does
that kind of howl of rage and grief and
have to do that how 20 times or
something it was such a phenomenal
performance and Richard to chew them it
was it was insane I mean we've been
waiting for for so long and dreading it
and then to have it turn out better than
we could have imagined mainly because of
these
these active service was just you know
michelle measure that over there I start
this Michelle and that moment just
before you touch the same the shuttles
lead there's so much pride and
tenderness in that moment I mean this is
this is a big moment this is a
life-changing moment obviously but just
that that you could choose a place a big
shop at like some parts and businesses
coming talk about finding that that are
the character and you place it you have
to it's like a piece of music you have
to work your way over
whatever word overplays you want to
discover as you go along but because I
had Richard by my side constantly who I
love and adore and trust and I had a
great script and David Nutter and those
were those one bit where they actually
had the music and it was something about
lenses is a key change in the music and
it's usually just it was like somebody
walked over your grave
it literally gave us a chill and that
was the moment that David wanted as she
serves everyone leaving the room when
the nights as people leave the room
darkens the light curves the
candlesticks that go I say the room gets
darker door closes men in using stripes
up and that's when she initially feels
that something is not right
let's talk about that topic you guys did
I just feel like making them also up
quiet because I guess you read to do a
kind of thunderstorms going on your head
but it's just all so somber and kind of
low-key it's one of those moments I mean
what young-sun care is here is our
composure ramesha body and and it was an
argument we've been having for years
because we always give the reins of cast
it had to be familiar had to be the song
that was in the audience's minds enough
the first quarter to come on like the
reaction they're talking about you'd
recognize it and think something's wrong
except that was the experience reading
the book where they start playing raise
the cast America you're thinking that's
not right but here you know for the show
those would actually say blatant ring
becomes bring all that people music and
there was an argument that Dan and I act
as going back you know in season one and
I was thinking what if it turns out that
rains of castamere is the show's themes
referred and become so famous and Dan
said it's comically different songs how
many different for me to come up with
something as catchy and and I got Dan
won that argument and bringing him up
this gorgeous piece of music and it's
just it's just wellness wanting things
that you know it's playing in my head
right now I think about how much easier
getting to the show
you know there's opening titles and how
magnificent Angus I guess and his title
sequence intro means talking
what would the show be without that all
these people who've given us so much of
their their brilliance I just feel like
for you jobs this precedence disease for
Sam because I feel just become be more
and more heroic was this with his new
family
[Applause]
yeah it's an interesting one for Sam
really I mean I think Sam's always been
I think that I think that one branch of
heroics is to our one branch of bravery
rather is to stick up yourself and ward
off bad vibes and I think it's braver
sometimes to absorb I'd just be the only
girl all the time and I think Sam had a
lot of that the interesting thing about
summers cell moved in his mind so long
he's an academic all those so he absorbs
information regarding amazing curiosity
about how things work in the world's
almost that stressful this year became
concrete especially for this example
completely yeah but the interesting
thing I found out about the way this
moment came about is the one woman that
turns his life around where he becomes
the hero was a moment of complete good
instinct it wasn't about I mean people
say that sound like is not
dragonglass killing White Walkers he
didn't he's sort of been broken into a
thousand pieces and he had to find a web
computer and it just so happened to
lucked out and found this thing the
answers were questioned and people have
been searching for for years and years
and years so sound is mr. galleries on
grain appeared the work um got instinct
and he found out that when he's placed
on the enormous pressure and he feels it
almost responsibility babies next time
he's going to stand up straight
it's a really beautiful dude yeah and I
think that's with something a father
take up his his kind of experience
politics isn't one thing it really
there's nothing that's not going to be
bestseller but I think I think it's a
kind of one Sam has been almost
destroyed spiritually by bad parenthood
I think was the nation at this one isn't
because you see this the killaby thing
but so far he figures that the John has
had over the years he sort of happened
particularly but he's also a charisma
junkie he's like drawn an ego like his
bigger than life see as far away as a
job yeah I think there's an equal parts
John's trying to find a paternal figure
which is are pushing thinking each other
fragmented
but but he's always drawn to these cars
he's big he's strong willed man that
made their they find him they want to
come no chills with raising Peter
therefore education his father to benjin
- yeah come on woman cordon off and then
mance rayder
and what he was interesting about what's
coming up is he gets sick of that and he
turns into that buzzing I think so yes
I don't know it's gonna be interesting
season to play or going out nothing sure
what I just found my cigarette
watching all three seasons to give out
if it's again that they'll all be
profound to me
for me the moment for for you girls the
seasons not when you're naked up there
but when you're most vulnerable and most
naked is that where we're trying to
stand out for John and reverse yong-gi
me
I really solve basically through to
herself yes I mean it's going against
her gut in Susan and the world invited
everyone life offices issues I mean ever
known and it's
here comes Long John snow man who which
didn't really beginning and and he
totally just flipped or her fine I mean
and suddenly she finds herself sticking
up someone who doesn't quite follow the
same route as how he doesn't have the
same beliefs but yet I was the entity by
she was completely vulnerable there bore
I mean that's one of those heartbreaking
things that are seen on television she's
being pulled away and she refuses those
around I can taste anger now a black
person America obviously but when thank
you question says this is who I am and
that's a real stand and this beautiful
moment thank you that was an amazing day
and is once again going straight up to
the writings that David had done they
write so beautifully in so intelligently
pick it isn't auto privilege and joy to
be an amazing to say I have some fun
watching all stuff we do with Charles
dance I mean talk about father figures
any father is warmed by fathers and the
whole you heart diseases kind of end on
fatherhood to funny relationship with
your father versus the idea of becoming
a father yourself we sort of making that
next step in marriage and you're his a
Tyrian same illness is that really
receiving wants to season oh no course
says so much about an actor when you
can't imagine any other actor playing
Roland Charles dance is that for me with
Tywin Lannister every time we have one
of those scenes Charles gives me a nice
little shoulder rub after each tape make
sure we still love one another developer
best bids because it gets you nowhere
that beautifully written cease and I
just I find this fascinating because
he's so frustrated for Tyrion because uh
his three children Jaime Cersei and
myself are so three different parts of
the whole and they don't they don't
they're not in the rape hope you've been
on the right person they each lap what
the other has but they're so aware of
their failures the material seems to be
basically sort of self-destructiveness
exactly the ways of what she's wrong
yeah and you can get away with it too
because has this freedom in terms of
financial freedom and all of that yes
the freedom in terms of threatening
Joffrey you know maker who sort of guy
um because he also knows that his father
who is the true what's basically ruler
feels the same way about Joffrey that I
did he just doesn't say it I just
thought we get this great family see as
we talking sir see about Joffrey and
about happiness and she says well I
guess there was a time I really was
happy you seem to be too shocked by his
anything else
yes like at you playing the silences
they're so beautiful
Thanks
you're only as good as the actors who
work with and I'm lucky to be working
with some really good ones
George have to ask is it true that you
were since you said last year it would
be in any country with its elevation
when the red wedding episode play if you
managed to stay away from TV during that
week though I I discovered that there
are no countries I mean in the last year
the folks have sold in Mongolia Iran
Vietnam you know so I decided there was
no no escaping in Iceland we had a nice
little evolves in an area now so my
figured I might as well just hunker down
in the Santa Fe and withstand a storm
and I managed to I managed to survive it
I had more experiences I went through a
small precursors from 30 years ago and
people were throwing a books into the
fireplace saying they would never never
read them the word of mine again and
then we'd go out and actually can buy
another copy and a book like that they
like no one to my knowledge through
their television since we're now talking
about this episode the fact that somehow
people managed to keep cool would keep
quiet about this I mean this is an
incredible compact between the people
who read the book is when I met you I
I love that I was afraid to ask you
about it what you trick me tensed I
honestly don't build it up so grateful
for it I mean I think you go to any of
the fan sites there's this kind of
incredible self-policing
that people do where where people are
shouted out they start spoiling anything
and and the sites are very carefully
monitored so that experience isn't
ruined for people we're coming to it
fresh and we're just incredibly grateful
for it you know there's always going to
be a couple of douches on message boards
you just want to tell you what happens
to whatever character but but for the
most part I mean the self-control that
so many people knew about is the
millions of people knew about the red
wedding before there and yet so much the
audience was was its darkest just makes
us really grateful title interesting was
because you guys are a are respectful
and incredibly attractive
and so though we're the shameless mammal
but I was assuming it's gonna happen one
way or another when you shop as well
that people get whine about things well
because we've had someone eat I feel
like for us the first season was sort of
the test case he agrees and and whether
or not people give us to build the beans
on what happened to to Ned Stark that
would let us know what we were you know
what we were looking at what we were
facing and the fact that so many people
managed to keep quiet but such a
monumental event in the story except my
mom except for this is mom people would
walk up and down the lines at the
bookstore telling everybody did you know
that syrup guys yeah I feel like after
they the fan bases all that it managed
to keep quiet about that I don't realize
we had one things I'm talking guys about
this before this kind Nick runs
throughout is just wake people the
counters deal with fear and immediate
few this season I always thought it so
again he's my kind of conquer that and
her fear himself doubt starts kind of
brought away this season the way that
the gun is striking and I want you to
talk about finding a way to play all
just heard through balls of confidence
after a while yeah well I mean coming
out of season two she was kind of
self-belief and confident in herself and
others was pretty rock bottom my
abilities Trust of being abolished and
then so going into season three my
rambling up to the scene and she had a
lot of self-doubt in a way definitely
and it's kind of seen the plans really
it's it was sort of him
it was the first time that she didn't
discuss anything with her closest
advisors it wasn't brought up with
surgery it was entirely a risk she was
taking and the trust that she put who is
into her dragons listen to what's on
your hands of history this kind of your
and amazing in it and it does and I just
think that she built that she just
builds from that continues to kind of
Sheila house advice and solicitors
pretty wonderful to get to play that to
sort of think about where she really
came from season one from the beginning
to that moment but just feels like these
last two episodes have come to define
the show in the way I wanted you guys
expected not only the red wedding with
the following episode just because
there's so much families are committed
for a second just the way you feel so
much pleasure in SME that again is
almost like your character is going to
build his way out of this I was
believing it wasn't going to happen and
you have to actually be that guy here to
play him instead of being invested a
book talk about just find the way to
play this moment where he thinks
everything is the way he wants it to be
that he's got the woman he loves it easy
to go to my grave exposure a kisser
don't I'm doing is trying to not p.m.
Tammy I think we all try to do that and
just try to make it realistic and it's
honest in Canada that's something that
the book said that you don't know what
turns high stability and how the actions
going to change I don't think that's
something done
all the answers do which is we commit
decisions and then destructor
and your characters going completely
deaf away and you have to force yourself
to go a different path and that keeps it
exciting that's what George deliberately
never know what's coming next and so as
a lot of you you have to think that's
what we've all done throughout the shows
you you commentor a decision and then
you get slammed with a curveball and you
take it that's what keeps us honest I
think the broad starting same venues
he's on this always committed in woman
and and then present and at that stage
but templates at night starts there is
nothing to say that this isn't going to
work and and he's he's done everything
he possibly can and it's his work time
as best as it could or what's happening
about it and we think things working
when we get to the stage is like right
from the book stretch actually this is
going to be a we're going to have this
amazing battle I'm going to scroll it to
things landing car shortly it's going to
be a great breakfast tomorrow quick
party they do and I last know what
happens and that's definitely not but I
think it's just about being present and
currently
what the writing guys that's what the
actors done that's what George does so
the artists all the time when we do that
we end up achieving things that are
quite interesting I think there may be a
couple of audience questions I'm not too
mistaken about this what the clip wait a
sec we come with new onyx
where's my boy I get to be on the
t-shirts the funny thing is I was
thinking about this the other day
because of this show we had to travel to
the most amazing places in Dubrovnik
there where that scene takes place we go
back there for a couple of weeks cos
here and I never been heard of Dubrovnik
before the show and now it's one of my
favorite places on this world wars and
but I hadn't taken a proper vacation and
I don't know how long because we get to
go to these places we work we work our
asses off but my job allows me to go to
the most beautiful places in the world
so it's incredible yes up next question
hi this questions this questions drags
it towards George as a fan of the show
I know at some point is good and the
books are going to be done
thus the shows can be done and well a
lot of the annual is here we'll want to
see that so my question is would you
ever consider doing a prequel series
maybe one or two books illustrating the
fall of the Targaryen the rice Iran
Baratheon that's what I thought
though the main thing is that let's
start moving back and the Sharpie won't
be dying in something it's something the
world kind of wants to see well first I
have to finish the winch of winter and
agree with spring that's going to take
me around awhile and
I have to write quickly here because
David and these guys are catching up to
me and I get you know the locomotive is
coming down the tracks behind me and I'm
still laying the tracks but they're not
quite on top of me yet but I can see the
smoke in the next hill there so I'm uh
I'm working on that then what I'm going
to write it that would I write others
stories that is no Westeros in the world
yeah I might
I don't think however it would be a
prequel about Robert's rebellion I mean
I've that material is being revealed
through flashbacks and revelations in
the course of the present series so by
the time I'm finished these less the
books I think you'll know everything
about that you'll have known all the
twists and turns and the trails and the
mysteries will be solved so writing up
and it's reading a book about that would
just be kind of connecting the dots
without any surprises but I might go
back earlier and write something that a
Don and his sisters or the man or a
conte unworthy a true true scumbag of
the king with his nine mistresses
so there's lots of material to write
about if I want to do more in Westeros I
just don't think I'll do the immediate
precursor so I'm sorry about that
no offense to Sean Bean that you know it
is really sad to see Sean died he's a
brilliant actor when he doesn't die so
well hi I'm Emily and this question who
I should write this much who goes to the
hill you see yourself so often we are
showing female characters who are
portrayed as weak because of their
femininity and one of the brilliant
things about Game of Thrones is that all
these women have such depth and strength
and your journey in particular has such
complexity and drink Bills of compassion
which as an aspiring actress is really
empowering so thank you for that but my
question to you is what is it like to be
such an icon of female power and would
you maybe I can't hear you I'm sorry
quite cut out you cancer getting to get
into play getting to say
the most glorious experience is an actor
I couldn't have dreams going strong so
that I would ever get to play such a
wonderful strong woman and reading
scripts and seeing her journeys is a
phenomenal experience and as a young
girl myself I think it's it kind of sort
of empowers me as a woman so it's
getting to getting to play that and it
is incredible George having written her
and David down having we're near to
absolute perfection
so it said it's quite an experience and
to have even the remotest possibility
that I've helps to make other women feel
empowered it is just the most wonderful
feeling I could possibly imagine so I'm
just incredibly grateful
[Applause]
oh so I'm a huge fan of the series and I
was before there's a huge fan in the
Harry Potter series and so with mine
that I was wondering if any of the
actors have a relationship like JK
Rowling and Alan Rickman where George
has told you guys about what's going to
happen in the future with your
characters no x2 it well just anything
to do with the future but it seems like
that answers some of the angers don't
want to know and some of the actors do
want to know so what I actually have is
a set if someone asked me out
I'll tell them but some really prefer
not to they'll interpret reduce
repetitive on and of course there is a
factor that the other things changed
that kind process going on so the books
of the books of the show is a show and
then don't know there I think the show
is very faithful -
identical to our changes so some of the
actors finding out what happens in the
books to their character doesn't
necessarily mean the same things that
happen in the scripts liquor and I guess
we are out of time so it's now done I'm
sorry I think it shows my bad next
season right good let's thank the
creator and the creator at the start
[Applause]